Trascrizione: Fabiola Summa
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buongiorno.
Desidero cominciare
questa chiaccherata con voi
parlando di un mio ricordo infantile.
Vi ricordate quando si giocava
al genio della lampada,
che poteva darci tre desideri da esaudire?
Quando giocavo con i miei compagni
e le mie compagne
dicevo sempre: be', ma ne basta uno!
Vorrei che tutte le persone,
le creature del mondo,
stessero bene.
Che fossero in armonia,
in pace, in serenità".
E senza saperlo, nella mia
gioiosa innocenza infantile,
anticipavo un po' il pensiero
del bene comune
che manifesta Riane Eisler.
Eisler ci parla della partnership,
che è nel mio titolo,
che tratta e parla della relazione:
fra esseri umani;
con la madre natura;
con lo spirito; nella società,
e via di seguito.
Eisler rintraccia due modalità:
una di dominio,
che vediamo alle mie spalle,
dove viene esaltata la violenza,
la sottomissione, lo stupro,
anche nell'arte;
noi possiamo trasformare
queste modalità di relazione
in relazioni verso la partnership.
Qui vedete due immagini da Creta:
l'unione con il mondo animale
e fra i partner.
Questo modello interdisciplinare
e interculturale proposto da Riane Eisler,
bambina ebrea in fuga dall'olocausto
e ora ottantottenne,
l'avete vista nella foto,
attivissima, insigne studiosa
di macrostoria, di cultura,
ci porta un'infinita energia,
un'infinita forza,
un desiderio ancora di essere attivo
come credo noi che siamo riuniti qui oggi,
per migliorare il nostro mondo,
per portare il nostro contributo.
Eisler ci ispira alla pace,
alla compassione fra persone;
e anche negli elementi
più personali del nostro vivere,
più intimi nelle nostre relazioni umane
insieme a quelle sociali, culturali,
economiche, politiche e spirituali
In questo libro, che vedrete,
la nostra vita parla di interconnessione:
nella famiglia, nella comunità,
con la Madre Terra.
Qui ci sono due immagini
che mi sono molto care:
vedete che la Terra, da lontano,
ci mette sempre un po'
le cose in prospettiva
"Il potere della partnership:
sette modalità di relazione
per una nuova vita"
è la traduzione più recente
che abbiamo pubblicato
nella collana All, che dirigo,
della casa editrice Forum;
e vedete in copertina
un'interessante rielaborazione
di un'artista friulana, Isabella Pers,
che riprende un ricordo
molto particolare di Eisler -
la bambina che vedete nel quadro,
nel dipinto, in realtà è Eisler -
poco prima che la sua vita fosse sconvolta
e fosse distrutta la vita
di milioni di persone.
Nel viaggio verso la partnership,
Eisler parla delle sette relazioni
della nostra vita:
esploriamole insieme.
La prima è il rapporto
con noi stessi e noi stesse:
il corpo, la mente, lo spirito,
ne abbiamo sentito parlare anche prima.
E a partire da questa relazione,
che è sempre un partnership
studies of art, che dirigo,
ha realizzato un laboratorio
artistico, virtuale,
nel rapporto fra tecnologie
umane e digitali
per riportarci al sapere
che i nostri corpi viventi
devono comunque mantenere questa qualità
all'interno di una società, troppo spesso,
solo ed esclusivamente virtuale.
Le artiste Tiziana ed Isabella Pers
insieme al collettivo
"Dalla maschera al volto"
coordinato da Alessandro Rinaldi,
hanno realizzato, durante
"Conoscenza in festa",
diciamo delle cartoline
per pubblicizzare questa iniziativa;
e come vedete,
c'è un neon che si intitola
"Living bodies blurring realities"
proprio per definire questa relazione.
In quell'occasione c'è stata
una dance performance,
a cura di Mattia Mantellato;
e uno story-telling,
coordinato da Piera Giacconi,
per ricordarci la bellezza,
l'importanza dello sguardo,
del movimento del corpo,
della voce, degli occhi, dell'anima.
Riviviamo insieme, oggi, un breve momento
di questa dance performance.
(Applausi)
Brave le nostre ragazze, vero?
il secondo tipo di relazioni,
di rapporti che Eisler analizza
sono i rapporti intimi.
È bene riflettere sul modo
in cui ci rapportiamo
alle altre e agli altri,
e anche con la nostra interiorità;
ci relazioniamo con aggressività, durezza,
oppure siamo accoglienti, ci incontriamo,
sappiamo emanare cura e amore?
Vi racconto un esempio personale:
tempo fa avevo un bravissimo studente,
quasi pronto per la laurea,
che è andato in crisi,
come a volte succede;
e non riuscivamo ad uscire
da questa problematica.
Quindi, avendo creato con lui
un rapporto di fiducia, empatico,
di cura e attenzione,
ad un certo punto ho avuto un'intuizione.
Ho detto: "Ma facciamo
un patto scritto fra noi due"
E abbiamo stilato un contratto
con lo scadenziario delle date
in cui doveva consegnarmi il materiale,
una serie di cose
con documento, firma:
insomma una cosa
abbastanza in piena regola.
Questo stratagemma, se volete,
è servito a spostare
il meccanismo dell'attenzione
dalla paura, dallo stress di concludere
al farlo con grande successo
con un bel 110 e lode.
E quindi, questo è un modo
in cui si può lavorare.
In questo volume, che vedremo,
il terzo rapporto
è quello con la comunità
che è un cerchio
sempre più ampio della cura.
Nel volume "La vera ricchezza
delle nazioni", sempre di Eisler,
Eisler parla dell'economia di cura,
e sottolinea l'importanza
dei lavori di cura
che sono fondamentali
come l'insegnamento,
prendersi cura dei bambini,
delle bambine, degli anziani,
che spesso però viene un po' trascurato
viene visto, viene sottopagato
e visto come non così importante.
Nei rapporti con la comunità
è fondamentale creare fiducia,
empatia, rispetto, comprensione;
solo così possiamo
manifestare la partnership.
Altro rapporto, numero quattro:
i "Rapporti con la comunità."
Perché la politica conta?
il primo passo che dobbiamo fare
è ricordarci, sapere,
avere la consapevolezza
che possiamo, insieme, fare la differenza.
Possiamo, e dobbiamo,
impegnarci con forza
per un'agenda politica
integrata, di partnership,
su quelli che Eisler chiama
"I quattro pilastri della partnership":
i rapporti d'infanzia mutuali,
perché nei rapporti con bambini e bambine
impariamo poi a relazionarci da adulti;
i rapporti di genere mutuali,
purtroppo stiamo vedendo, tutt'ora,
una forte recrudescenza di femminicidio.
Ovviamente, se non impariamo
da piccoli e da piccole a relazionarci,
abbiamo difficoltà;
l'economia mutuale:
come vi dicevo prima,
un'economia di cura che pensi
alla sostenibilità delle cose;
e importantissimo, la quarta credenza,
la credenza culturale, il mito, la storia
che siano a supporto della partnership.
L'importante è quello
che ci raccontiamo sulla nostra vita.
Eisler, nel parlare dei rapporti
con la comunità internazionale,
e con il mondo intorno a noi,
rivoluziona un po',
come spesso fa in tutti i suoi libri,
le nostre abitudini di pensiero;
indica il prevalere
di quello che lei chiama
il modello di dominio
in società che apparentemente
noi giudicheremmo diverse, distanti
dal punto di vista culturale,
storico, geografico.
E infatti, dice così:
Non esiste differenza
fra la Germania di Hitler,
l'Iran di Khomeini,
il Giappone dei Samurai,
gli Atzechi della Meso-America,
la Cina di Mao,
il fondamentalismo religioso
di qualunque colore:
Tutte queste società,
per altri versi molto diverse,
sono rigidamente a dominio maschile.
Possiedono una struttura gerarchica
e un alto grado di violenza.
Quindi, quando sentiamo
le news in televisione
siamo conpartecipi di quello che accade.
Se sentiamo parlare della fame del mondo,
delle violenze verso le donne,
dei danni umani, artistici e planetari
delle guerre, dell'inquinamento,
della globalizzazione, dello sfruttamento,
non è una statistica
anonima: riguarda noi.
Altrettanto importante è il rapporto
con la Natura, con la Madre Terra:
osservare il cosmo con le sue dimensioni -
vedete quanto è piccina la Terra -
mi aiuta sempre un po'
a ridimensionare le questioni,
ad avere una prospettiva diversa relativa.
E la partnership, si diceva,
comincia da noi.
Per le sei nazioni native irochesi,
bambine e bambini devono essere
il fulcro di ogni nostro pensiero,
devono portarci ad assumere
le nostre decisioni politiche, legali,
pensando alle generazioni future
nel rispetto della Madre Terra,
della vita, del bene comune.
Nella settima relazione,
quella spirituale,
possiamo ricordare,
insieme a tutti i popoli nativi,
che è fondamentale tutelare e celebrare
la bellezza e il miracolo
della vita e dell'amore.
In una società sempre più frenetica,
e iper-tecnologica e iper-razionalista
è bene imparare, ricordare di fermarci.
Allora, facciamolo insieme: fermiamoci.
Chiudete gli occhi, e seguitemi.
Sentite, e percepite,
la tensione del vostro respiro
la tensione della vostra
postura sulle sedie,
quindi un po' la chiusura:
noi tendiamo a respirare sempre
con la parte alta dei polmoni.
E inspirate profondamente,
ed espirate profondamente,
per due o tre volte;
fate un bel respiro profondo
e inspirate ed espirate.
Adesso semplicemente, in modo naturale,
lasciate che il respiro fluisca
e concentratevi sul respiro.
(Respira)
Thich Nhat Hanh, monaco vietnamita,
dice una cosa che mi piace molto:
"Inaliamo calma, esaliamo sorrisi".
Dovremmo ricordarcelo, spesso.
In conclusione,
se volete riaprire gli occhi
e riprendere un po' contatto
con il vostro corpo, con l'ambiente
percepite una differenza dentro di voi,
e forse anche nell'ambiente.
Ovviamente, l'abbiamo dovuta tenere
molto breve, questa tecnica;
però la potete ripetere tranquillamente
in qualunque occasione
e in qualunque circostanza.
In conclusione,
desidero raccontarvi una storia
che mi è molto cara,
e che troviamo nel libro
"Donne che corrono coi lupi"
di Pinkola Estès:
si intitola "Tre capelli d'oro".
Pinkola Estès, come Eisler,
è stata per me, personalmente,
una lettura trasformativa, importante.
Questa storia in particolare
è una storia di rigenerazione,
di trasformazione,
ci parla del bisogno ciclico, e circolare,
di una persona che ci culli
e che si prenda cura di noi.
"C'era una volta,
in una notte nera e profonda,
un vecchio che attraversava,
barcollando, un fitto bosco.
Teneva in mano una candela,
che emanava una luce sempre più fioca.
Il vecchio aveva lunghi
capelli gialli, e denti gialli;
era curvo e avanzava
con un'enorme fatica.
Infine in lontananza vide
una piccola luce, una casetta.
Si diresse lì,
arrancando e trascinando
il suo corpo sempre più esausto.
Quando arrivò alla porta, crollò sfinito.
La vecchia, padrona del casetta,
lo prese in braccio
e lo portò accanto
al suo bel fuoco ruggente.
Si sedette sulla sedia a dondolo,
con il vecchio in braccio,
e lo cullò come una grande madre.
Immaginateli:
il povero vecchio, tutto ossa;
e la forte vecchia che lo cullava
avanti e indietro, avanti e indietro
ripetendo: ecco, ecco, ecco.
Lo cullò per tutta la notte.
E man mano il vecchio
si era trasformato:
prima in un adulto, poi in un bel giovane,
finché all'alba era divenuto
un bel bimbetto neonato.
La vecchia allora gli strappò
dalla testolina dorata tre capelli d'oro,
e li gettò in terra.
I tre capelli, cadendo,
fecero un bel tintinnio
fresco e cristallino.
Il bimbo scivolò giù
dal grembo della vecchia,
corse alla porta, si girò a guardarla
e sorrise di un sorriso luminosissimo.
Poi si volse, e salì in cielo,
per diventare lo splendido
Sole del mattino.
Grazie per il dono del vostro tempo.
(Applausi)